- And I feel like, I was like,
I don't think we've ever,
I've seen you so much.
- Yes.
- I feel like we've met,
but we've never met.
- We haven't.
- Yes.
- But I feel like
we know each other.
- I feel like we're connected.
I feel like I'm in a choosing to be a part
of your sisterhood.
- So wait-
- You're in.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- That was an easier way
to get in.
- You're in.
You are a part of our
sisterhood right away.
- Thank you, thank you.
So wait, you guys both have kids now.
We all have kids, very young as well.
You have a real young-
- I have a little baby,
six month year old.
- Six month year old.
(everyone laughs)
- Six months is so young.
Are you sleeping?
- I'm sleeping.
- Yours is a good baby.
- She likes to sleep.
I feel guilty for anyone in the audience
that has a little baby.
She likes to sleep.
- Oh, you are so lucky.
- I'm so lucky.
- I have a puppy right now at my house.
- Are you sleeping?
- No.
(everyone laughs)
- It was a good idea
- When was the last time
you slept?
- on paper.
- When was the last time
you slept, honestly?
- I sleep, but it's just
broken up because she's little.
So she has a little bladder.
So, I mean, around three
in the morning-
- I think we have a bit
of a similar situation in that way.
- That's what I'm saying.
It's like having a baby.
- The tiny bladder club.
- Yes.
- Yeah, but at least
that one's wearing a diaper.
(Jenna and Barbara laughs)
I wish we had doggy diapers.
I just let her go, and then
give her a bath every day.
I'm like, it's hard.
You forget like, wait, but you don't.
You're in it.
And your kids are young too though, right?
- My youngest is two.
- I was gonna say that.
- Yeah.
- My youngest is five.
- I just potty trained him,
so I feel..
(Kelly gasps)
- You're out of diapers?
- I'm out of diapers.
- It's a victory.
- That's a victory.
- I feel so proud of myself.
(audience applauding)
- Look at their face! (laughs)
- I know.
(both laughing)
- Oh, my God!
- Doesn't that look
like a little man who's potty trained?
- Oh, my God.
- He was like, "I just did
something in my pants."
- He's like, "I got."
- Yeah, exactly.
That was before potty train,
when the diapers were around.
- Oh, my God.
That's a beautiful thing,
when like bottles and diapers
kind of just drift away.
- We're out, I know.
- That's amazing.
- But now, I'm sort of like,
do I have another one?
But no, I mean...
- Yeah.
- Oh my God that hits us.
That's what we do.
- Yes, I know!
- Why do we do...
- It's evolutionary.
- We forget.
Yeah, you forget how mine was miserable.
Did she give you any motherhood advice?
- Well, I got to see her be a mom.
That's how I learned to be a mom.
But my little nugget shocked me,
and she came almost six weeks early.
When I wasn't in New York,
which is where I live.
I was in Maine.
- Yeah.
- I woke up at four in the
morning, and I went into labor,
and all of a sudden I'm
googling hospitals nearby.
- What?
- And we made it.
- I would've been terrified.
- Yes.
- I mean, I was, but I didn't
know what was ahead of me.
So it was sort of-
- Oh, my gosh.
- the unknown, I didn't know.
- Yeah.
- Anyway, we made it.
She arrived like an hour after
we arrived at the hospital.
And she had to be in the NICU
for the first four weeks,
and we were totally unprepared.
We thought she was gonna come
on her due date.
- Yeah.
- So my sister, luckily, flew
to Maine, went to Target.
- Oh, where you can get it all.
- Got everything.
- Yeah, I got, and by the way,
I know what to get.
I'm like, okay, yes to the Aquaphor,
yes to the diapers.
- Yeah, like the diapers,
the car seat.
We had no means of taking her home
from the hospital.
- Yes.
- So I don't know that she gave me advice,
but she just stepped up and
helped me get that little nugget
through her first few months of life.
- Yeah.
- And her name is Cora Georgia Coyne.
Georgia after my dad and grandfather.
So my dad just calls her, C-George.
(everyone laughs)
- C-George?
It's like she's learning to read.
"See George run."
"See George play."
- "See George walk."
- Yeah, so she doesn't
know what to answer to.
- Yeah.
- But all of their grandkids call them,
my dad's nickname is Jefe,
which means "the boss" in Spanish.
- Okay, I like that.
- Which was like self-chosen.
- Its self-appointed, yeah.
- He chose it.
- Yeah.
(everyone laughs)
- It wasn't like a little
grandchild was like,
"I'm gonna call you Jefe."
He'd chosen in advance
and now has taught them that.
- Yes.
- Basically, he was in retirement
and nobody was calling
him "The Boss" anymore.
- So he was, yeah.
- So he is like, "Hey, you."
- It was a power struggle.
- Yeah, a little bit.
- Yeah, I love that.
That's a cool name.
So you guys turned 40 a few months ago.
So, what should I be prepared for?
Everybody keeps saying,
I'm gonna just go blind.
- You are.
- What?
- And somebody said that to me.
- Its odd.
- Like Hoda and Savannah.
- What about lasik surgery?
- We got it.
(Kelly gasps)
- But it doesn't matter.
Savannah and Hoda said, "When you turn 40
you're gonna need readers
like the day after".
And I was like, "No, no, no,
I've got great eyesight."
- I have like 20/20.
- Oh, no.
- The day after, I was like.
- You know what though?
I'm looking forward to
some cute little readers.
- Yeah.
- And looking astute.
- Because we brought you-
- Oh, you did?
- we brought you a little gift.
- A happy birthday gift.
- Oh.
(audience applauding)
- I love this!
- First of all, can we just show,
so those are the cutest as we were hoping.
- Whatever, these are gonna be
my readers.
- They're kind of
Harry Potter like.
- I'm into Harry Potter.
- That's cute.
Daniel Radcliffe.
- Do you know what these are?
- Cowboy boots.
- These are the official
Dallas Cowboys cowboy boots.
- Are these pompoms?
(audience cheers)
- Those are the pompoms
- Wait for it.
because we know that
you are from Dallas too.
And we wanted to make sure that you were.
- Wait, I wasn't a cheerleader.
I didn't know poms were on both sides.
- By the way, you think
we were cheerleaders?
- Yeah, they didn't accept this.
- No.
- They were like, "You're crazy."
I thought they only had poms on one side.
They have double.
- Yeah, that's for dancing.
- Double poms.
- These are legit.
- But these boots are for you.
- I love them!
- For your 40th.
Oh, and we got you an Aerosmith t-shirt
because we know you-
- You know me so well!
- We knew you were.
(audience cheering)
- What?
Aerosmith combined with Texas.
- We also got you some tweezers
'cause hairs grow in places.
(audience laughs)
- It's a 40s thing.
- Hairs grow in places.
- You guys, literally,
this is a real story.
And I'll take 'em.
(audience laughing)
I was on a vacation with my girls,
and all of a sudden I came in
and how the light was hitting my face,
I had a full on blonde beard.
- Yeah.
- At least it's blonde.
- It's so blonde.
But it glistens in the sun,
like I'm a vampire on "Twilight."
It's literally the sunrise.
And then my friend came in and I thought,
for sure Trisha was
gonna be like, "Oh, no."
Suddenly, she was like,
"Oh, my God, you do!"
And I was like, "Aah!"
And it literally, I just
have so much peach hair.
It's like a...
I have a blonde beard.
- Yeah.
- Well, listen-
- Ours isn't always blonde.
Let's just put it that way.
- Where did it come from?
No.
Then randomly TMI, random
black witch hairs in my chin!
- Look at these women.
- They're like we know.
- And it wasn't there at night time.
(audience laughing)
- It came in the morning.
- Somehow
it grew in the night.
- Yeah.
- And I had a hair and
it was like, "What?"
And it hurt.
- Well, that's why you need
a sister to pluck it for you.
Sometimes you need a good angle.
- I can't, I will punch someone.
I have to pluck myself.
- We'll do it for you.
- Some people try and do it.
I'm like it hurts.
But when I do it, it doesn't hurt.
I love your gifts.
- Well anyway, happy birthday.
- Wait, wait what's this?
This is your book.
- Oh yes.
- Wait, I wanna
look in here.
- I put it in there
and we forgot.
- No, no, yes, wait.
So it's called "The
Superpower Sisterhood".
I love this.
I read to my kids every night.
We've done the camping one that you did.
- Yes.
- So I've done that one.
So my kids are gonna love this.
- Oh, we hope so.
- Why did y'all wanna do this?
What's it about?
- Well, it's about sisterhood.
It's the love letter to
sisterhood, both blood sisters
like us or besties that are like sisters.
We wrote a children's book
called "Sisters First"
a few years ago.
And on tour, all these
women would come up and say
"I don't have a sister,
but I brought my best friend with me."
- Yeah.
- And we were like, "Well,
that's your sister."
Sisterhood can be so much bigger.
And so our story is
about a girl named Emma.
Who's an only child.
The way that our mom was.
- Yeah.
- And she starts his
sisterhood with the other girls
on her block.
And they're super powerful.
- They're super powerful.
- Their super powers
aren't like supernatural.
That's what I love.
- Yes, it's like, one is good at math,
one is like you and is excellent at music,
one's a dancer,
one's an architect.
But like together.
And I feel like we all know
this with our best friends.
- Yeah.
- Like we want friends
that light us up, you know?
- Yeah.
- And that find the beauty in us
and make us feel super power.
- Yeah.
- And that's super powerful.
- Absolutely, wait, what
were your super, like,
What was your super power
you feel like growing up?
- Barbara's superpower.
- I never shut up.
- That's mine.
- But you have a real superpower also.
- Yeah, you're
an incredible musician.
- You actually are.
- You forgot about that part.
- No one cared about
singing when I was a kid.
They were just like, "Stop talking."
- But you understand
that that's the power.
If we..
- I love talking.
- If we could, I'm a talker.
I would give up talking for singing.
- I don't know if I could do that.
Yeah, I don't know if I could not talk.
- I would give up talking for singing
but Barbara's superpower was math.
- When I was little
- She won...
No, no Barbara don't belittle yourself.
You're still
excellent at math.
- I'm not, but I think
I peaked in third grade.
- Barbara, no, you didn't.
She won the "Dallas
state math competition"
in third grade.
- Oh, you were like
one of those mathletes.
- Yeah, mathlete.
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
- My mom found the trophy and
mailed it to me last year.
So it's on my fireplace mantle.
- Oh my God,
I love that.
- But I never,
unfortunately, everything
sort of was downhill
after third grade, but
it was a good moment.
- I hope and pray when you
have people over at your house,
you're like, "And here's
my mathlete trophy."
- Oh yeah,
and my trophy is out.
- That's my favorite.
I love that.
What were you good at?
What was like your superpower?
- Well she did-
- I was a well-fed
chubby little Texan.
(everyone laughs)
Okay.
And I would try out for
Les Miserables every year.
- She was desperate
to be Cosette.
- I wanted to be baby Cosette.
- But it wasn't like, her look wasn't
the French revolution exactly.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- That's only a sister can say
that that's me and my sister.
(audience laughing)
- I was like, "But what
about this doesn't scream
the French Revolution?"
- Literally Ran is pointing to break.
- He's like "Its time!
What are y'all talking about?"
- You got three Texas women here.
That's your fault!
(everyone laughs)
Okay, Jenna and Barbara's new book.
"The Superpower Sisterhood" is out now.
You gotta check it out.
You can also see Jenna
cohost "The Today Show"
every morning on NBC and
follow her book club,
"Read with Jenna".
I love the you a book club.
We're playing a game
because I'm making them
and I love games.
- We love it.
- Okay, good.
And it involves sisters in the eighties.
And you're welcome. Stay here.